[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're wrapping up the year with
one of my favorite episodes that we do
at the end of every year our top 10
moments
this year
2022. now I know that you have your
you're having a rough time today and it
kind of I mean you looked apart I gotta
really I gotta admit dang man like no
I'm just saying that like uh when I came
in this morning you were already lying
on the couch
um when we're recording this you're
still pretty early on in your injury
you're still you're adjusting to it
um I do want you to know that uh your
wife called me this morning
um after you left oh yeah just okay I
know what she's no just to let me know
that you're having a difficult time I
did not tell her that I was taking a
crap when she called me
um I guess I'm telling her that now but
she may have noticed the echo in the
vote my voice you didn't like flush in
the middle no I didn't in fact I stopped
no no actual defecation took place while
I was talking to your wife because I
felt like that would be inappropriate
I'm just letting you know but I was I
answered it because I was like Christy
doesn't usually call me is everything
okay like I thought she was gonna say
something like link broke his other
shoulder or something like you know but
she just said that you're having a
difficult time just getting ready
getting out of the house and then when I
came in you're lying down and you look
you you look you look frazzled like you
haven't been able to shave obviously
you're growing your Kenny Rogers beard
and your hair still looks like you
stopped it with your left hand but
you're in the early stages you're gonna
figure this out I'm here for you I'm
just acknowledging that you're going
through a difficult time that's week
that Christy called you
um which brings me to my number ten
you know we each made our list we didn't
share these with each other so we're
gonna go in reverse order
um yeah I decided to put breaking my
collarbone is my number 10 moment of the
year because it's very fresh on my mind
only number 10.
well
um one of my criteria for making my list
was you know at our age it's hard to
make core memories
something that then sticks with you for
the rest of your life but I think easily
making that one of the criteria breaking
my collarbone becomes one of my core
memories so it's I think it had to go on
my list oh easily you know for it to be
you know it could be six weeks of
recovery here maybe more hopefully less
um I still haven't had my Ortho
follow-up so I don't know exactly what's
going on but uh or start at any PT
anything like that but yeah I will
always remember
that I broke my clavicle because I
always remember breaking my pelvis and
that's the only thing that I've broken
reduce your pelvis in your clavicle yeah
so I mean this is kind of a big moment
towards the end of the year here for me
and it remains to be seen how much of an
impact it will continue to have I was I
mean
I mean I know for Good Mythical Morning
like
yeah because I mean through January I'm
gonna be in freaking slang
for the for the episodes yeah
so yeah this morning it was tough I'm
still making an adjustment I'm
the worst part of my day is getting up
and getting going I mean it's everything
has to change and I've been like you
know what I'mma have I'm gonna have a
positive attitude about this I'm gonna
see this as
an opportunity or a series of
opportunities but man it just kind of
beats you down when it's you just can't
get anything together like so I finally
got ready I got everything done and like
um I was about to leave I was putting on
my socks and shoes and I and you know I
don't want to I don't I don't ask
Christy and the kids to help me do
everything because I want to figure out
you know if this is
a mini weeks process I don't want it to
be like every time I put on socks for
like a member of my family to come over
and like to hold half of the sock right
right so I finally I get on my socks and
my shoes and I'm just like
Chrissy's in the kitchen and I'm I go
over to her and I'm like
I need a hug
because I'm like okay if you I'm
learning to and this this will be
another point on my
and on my on my list today but just
learning to express my needs in a way
that is appropriate right so it's like
for me it's like I need a hug I need a
hug so then Christy like stops what
she's doing and she I try to I had to
tell her how to give me a hug no don't
too tight don't put the arm up here put
the arm I need a side hook down here I
needed I definitely needed a front hug
and then
I'm just hugging her for
a prolonged period okay and then uh
with my head on her shoulder and then
she's like
are you
crying
or are you laughing
and I'm like both
I'll do both man it's okay man
okay yeah I was I mean it's just like
this
frustration and it's I'm I'm still
really grateful that I'm I'm not really
in any pain so it's really just this
frustration of like trying to get
together
um and then the amount of I don't know
it's just like so I was laying on the
couch when I got here because I was like
I told you I'm just
it's exhausting it's exhausting to
figure this stuff out you know how I
think about things like
oh my systems are broken yeah it's
especially hard on you it's hard on me
but it's because you do things exactly a
certain way that you've perfected in
each step so when that every single step
has been compromised that's it's been
cut in half it's like the the dominant
arm has been taken away so I'm really
excuse me I'm really trying to see it as
an opportunity it's like what what can I
learn from this how can I you know it
could be a lot worse Chrissy was like
thank God you didn't hit your head you
know that could that could have altered
your life for many years if not forever
and I was like how do you know that she
was like I've done some reading
so it's an opportunity for your left arm
once I get here
I'm
the worst part's over
like that's how I look at it
well if you need a hug just let me know
so I'll be laughing and crying on your
shoulder I mean it I was legitimately
thinking about afterward as I was
driving in I was like you know the
phrase is shoulder to cry on it's like
oh yes I actually took advantage of a
shoulder to cry on and um that's a good
thing it's a good thing it it it did
help you know you got a wife and you
know enjoyed it I think she liked did
she so when she called you did she go
into that Detail no it's like she was
like crying and laughing at the same
time she said that he broke down a
little bit
ah so I did that picture just crying on
her shoulder but now I do
well it was a beautiful moment one of my
top ten minutes
downhill from here is that and I
probably it's probably too soon to use
that joke
because that's how you hurt yourself
yeah going down yeah yeah so I put that
in my number 10 man
um my number 10 is adopting Sean
our new dog I love the look on your face
he made the list
Sean is really growing on me I love that
little guy
um he as a matter of fact Jesse
you know was recently she was when we
went to North Carolina she stayed a
little bit longer uh working on some
stuff and so Shepherd and I came back
and so I had some time with him and he
he's he's he's really connecting with me
and you saw the other day when we were
having all those meetings at
the creative house just you know digital
meetings
he's coming up to me all the time he he
came up to you and jumped in right in
your lap right when we came when I came
over I was shocked because I had a hat
on and he's afraid I had I thought he
was jumping in my lap to like to to eat
my crotch well I shouldn't have said it
that way to bite me like he did the last
time
I came to work and he was there yeah he
bit you twice but you said it was
because he was on a leash but he was
like yeah he jumped up I think he's
accepted petting he's learning to trust
people he's a learning he's learning to
trust people whatever wherever he came
from there he developed reasons to not
trust people and to not trust strangers
um and so I you know he's still in the
house
but it's a little bit more a little bit
easier to deal with he's so cute he's
his hair is growing in he's actually
becoming like he's more attractive he's
becoming the dog that I clicked on right
on the website he's a lot more petable
and uh so he and you know what he
remains a challenge and an opportunity
not quite like you're clavicle
um but it's sort of like he's he's a
little project in some ways for our
family to be like Barbara's so easy
loves everybody the only thing wrong
with Barbara is she'll steal the food
out of her hand and we cannot somehow
cannot stop her from doing that but
she's great in every other way very well
behaved well trained doesn't crap you
know it pee anywhere except outside Sean
is a little bit of a project but I think
it's teaching us patience as a family
and it's you know you got to put him on
the list because I mean in addition to
the family
is absolutely a core memory because I'm
right about that right it you know
there's certain things that for years to
come maybe the first of your life you'll
you'll refer back to
Sean now and this was the year of Sean
well hopefully there's more years of
Sean yeah the first year you know yeah
right
uh you know I I I completely agree he's
changed the dynamic of our family in a
positive way
um and my number nine I put our college
friend trip at my number nine I put our
College friends we're such in sync man
this is great that means that I we
didn't steal it from each other this is
my favorite thing we don't look at each
other's lists it looks like you're
looking at it now I can't read it from
there okay
it was I mean the ones on our list that
we've talked about in more detail in
other episodes we can gloss over a
little bit but you know I will say that
it was the culmination of
re-establishing a relationship over the
entire pandemic
and with us meeting in person
and it now it leads to that being
something that we've already planned I'm
gonna do it again
um to go on another trip in June I
believe uh we're gonna we're gonna take
white water rafting to the next level
I'm a little nervous I know now that
I've proven the fragility of my body to
myself
because we're up in the ante
significantly so much so that the upper
animus we're doing a series of class
five Rapids which was the most intense
that we could find
in Colorado at that time of year hey man
you gotta have fun and they were like
well you need to come
the day before and do a swim test and
I've been on many white water rafting
trips including the upper golly right in
West Virginia this is comparable to that
I didn't do no swim test for that I know
that got me feeling nervous man but that
was also the 90s or the early 2000s
probably
you're saying that standards have
increased I bet so safety the liability
stuff you know all of that so yeah now
we're we're going to have two trips on
our belt it may become an annual thing
and you know our girls trip
it's essentially what it is I think it's
our girls trip yeah I like that idea
um and just kind of knowing that it's
going to happen yeah I think that there
was something because otherwise I'm
sorry I cut you off I think oh
turn it over a new Leaf
no in my mind I started talking before
is this what I have to look for in 2023
that you're not going to cut me off but
you're going to realize that when you've
done it and not do it I am trying but I
don't want to like make it a resolution
or anything
I can't tell you how much I appreciate
that it's like it was like a hug
uh thanks for thanks for the feedback
but I mean if you I mean don't twist my
titty about it because
um oh now I forgot what I was gonna say
I got so excited
um no I think that one of the things
that made it so significant is the fact
that obviously we have a very uh unusual
relationship
in terms of me and you the longevity
that of our friendship and the fact that
we were friends as kids and friends all
throughout different pivotal times and
we're still friends and still working
together and
um
but the only other people really in our
lives at this point that
they're I'm trying to think of the way
to explain this if you go back 20 years
and you know this friendships last have
been around for a long time and outside
of family those are some of the only
people that we have connected with on
that level after all this time which is
just a really beautiful thing to be able
to happen I mean I I hope that that can
happen for other people just be like hey
you you formed this friendship at a
pivotal time
and may it's not always easy especially
when you're in different parts of the
country to maintain that that
relationship and those friendships but
the pandemic gave us that opportunity
now we're kind of cashing in on it by
being able to create experiences
together
um and also it's you know as we
discussed when we talked about that trip
on the episode it's a really
um you know we're all in different
places we all met in a very particular
context we all met in a campus ministry
context and we've talked many times
about where we're at in regards to that
and they're in a different everybody's
in a different place in regards to that
uh but there's still a really a real
closeness and honesty authenticity in
our relationship and so I just think
it's a really it's really a thing so
nourishing to reconnect with people who
yeah our our beliefs have drifted in in
various directions
and maybe I don't want to insinuate that
we've all drifted or whatever you know
what I'm trying everyone's changed
everybody's evolving but like
um yeah that our friendship can still be
so strong and so supportive and that
love can still be the center of it is
very
uh it's it ministers to my soul you know
what I'm saying
um even though
our video chats have kind of fallen off
at least we know that we have this trip
coming up and that that we kind of have
that Cadence now because to me that's
that's how I see the video chats were
the uh the beginning of a foundation
that now we're building on it with these
trips that we can schedule and there's
the text thread yeah that continues
um just one note I want to make uh
really just for us
um
it does give me an idea about something
like the ideas that we've been logging I
have one that like is semi-related to
this okay so actually a couple so I'm
just going to remember that by saying it
out loud and you can help me remember so
we can put it on the list of stuff for
the 2023 list okay
so it's your go so my number eight
I'm skipping ahead because
you just covered my number nine
um I do know for a fact this is on your
list because we just already discussed
it and I'm assuming it's higher on your
list but let's go ahead and it I there's
a reason that it's at this level on my
list okay
um we had a I'm gonna call it our most
my most surreal one of the most surreal
experiences of my entire life in a lot
of ways and definitely the most
Loosely stated Hollywood experience of
my life the most
I've ever experienced anything because
of the privilege that we have because we
have a successful internet show and that
is being invited to the the studio with
post Malone
oh yeah as he was working on his most
recent album now
you really stole my thunder here
he didn't make a number one did you this
is my number two okay so I knew it would
be high on your list yeah this is this
is this
it's interesting so it's tough to it's
tough to order the list yeah it is and
it's it's it's a bit you know it they're
it's a bit thrown together but the rule
is if you ranked it higher you get to
talk about it first so oh
well
this is one that
I mean we had a conversation about this
one that's why we knew that it was on
both of our lists because we were both
trying to figure out
if we wanted to put it out there
publicly you know I think we're very
sensitive to like the fact that you know
you know first of all you don't want to
sound like braggy
like oh I know somebody who's like like
telling a story for clout
we're not doing that and you also don't
want we don't want Austin to
um
feel like we're trying to take advantage
of the fact that he's been gracious
towards us
for cloud for for and to be like oh can
we get it let's get a selfie together so
we can show it on the internet right now
so right we don't do that we don't do
that
um
but this is this is such a huge moment
that yeah just to just to talk about
that night I think is something that we
agreed that was like I kind of kind of
have to talk about it so we'll you know
we're excited to let you in on it
especially because it's something that
we haven't shared a lot of this stuff
we've shared before this was so
um when it came on the show
we
then it was basically implied hey if you
want maybe we should hang out
and then he invited us that so it was
like February March and I would say the
first time he ever came on the show the
first time he came on the show after we
finished the show he was like what do
you guys doing the rest of the day right
and we were like well we're making more
GMM we're doing what we do every day and
we're shooting GMM so we didn't get we
didn't we never hung out after the first
time which is like a I was like man that
was such a big regret
I was like I'm not gonna make that
mistake again yeah if there's an
invitation right so then
um you know we set the night we were
gonna hang out
and don't make this my story we're both
there so I mean we're just kind of like
fill in the gaps but
um
yeah he was like we whatever you guys
want to do if you want to come by the
studio and so when he once he mentioned
the stew as he put it I was like yes
that's what I want to do I just yeah
let's let's hang out so we so we go over
there to the studio
and we meet Lou as producer and um
there's just a couple other friends of
his hanging out but it's like
one room
uh very dark
um with like the console and then back
to the left there's like the booth with
the window
so it's a pretty intimate space and we
go in there and we're just you know it's
we had you just you see how much fun we
had on the show you know it's it always
blew my mind about how much of a fan he
was and is of GMM so it's like
and and you saw how it wasn't good
Mythical More we were just like talking
about the gas station pills and like so
when we were setting up going to hang
out like we were making jokes about I
don't want to have any of those gas
station pills there was a lot of
laughter the entire time we we yeah we
just kind of picked up right we're
making each other laugh the whole time
and then playing music we were
connecting over our love of music and
specifically country music so there was
a lot of in fact there was one time
there was a period of time where there
was like a Hank Jr versus Hank senior
battle where we would pick a Hank Jr
song and he would pick a hank senior
song and we would play them like a
versus Battle which is which is
hilarious and that lasted I mean hours
we were there a very long time and just
kind of getting the story of like and we
don't stay we don't do that your bedtime
is 9 30. I mean I do stay up till
midnight on a relatively regular basis
but this was as we crept into the wee
hours of the morning I was like I guess
this is just how he rolls oh yeah it's
like he he goes to bed he's nocturnal
when the sun comes up
um and yeah I do I'm so fascinated about
the creative process that I couldn't
help myself but just kind of dig into
like his relationship with
Lou and like how how much how they
collaborate and
um you know they were playing playing
like
uh preliminary tracks of things that
then became like massive hits you know I
was just like
I was just like a kid in a candy store
like I couldn't sit down it was pretty
obvious I couldn't sit down like I'm not
you know yeah and I'm like you know what
I don't I I am if I'm gonna fanboy
I'm just going to do it you know it's
like over the especially if it's over
the music like I'm not I think he
understood that like I was like
fanboying over like the creative process
and the the music and not the fact that
like oh my God it's so cool to meet you
you know it's a in my mind it's a
different thing so it's like
just to like really connect with
something that an artist is making to
the point where it's like if they're
gonna play something for you you're
gonna get up and Shake Your Ass Like
that's just the decision I made like
dance like nobody's watching right and
it's and it's not it doesn't have to be
everybody's decision well there's a
reason that there's two of us yeah yeah
yeah I appreciate that so yeah I was uh
I mean yeah and at certain moments yeah
I was kind of in like music journalism
mode where it's like how give I have to
understand
and they were you know I think they were
both very into the conversation because
they were like oh playing this playing
that play them plan this demo and then
um you know at the time we were talking
about the the Neon Moon cover that we
made oh yeah for the mythical Society
because we were playing so much country
music we were talking about that and
and I think at one point
I said or one of us said like well I'll
make a deal with you
we'll play this song for you
under one condition
and he's like what he I was like that
you play a song of like give us a sneak
peek of a song off your off your album
because I know it's uh you know I know
it's coming out soon that you finished
it and he was like well I want to play
the whole album yeah like he was
planning on doing it anyway yeah he was
like I
yeah I'm not gonna play a song I'll only
play if you listen to the whole thing
and I'll never forget that moment
because I was like I was already like
the kid in the candy store and then I'm
like
we're looking at each other and we're
like yes this is amazing so we just we
sat there
and we just listened to the entire
completed pretty it was I mean every
song was sequenced finished all but one
song fully baked
and I remember sitting there uh and this
is when it hit me and why it stands out
and I would say if you're talking about
exact slices of time like one moment I
do recognize why this is higher on your
list and it and I it's just you'll
understand why you know there's other
things that are higher on the list later
but this Mo this Slice of Life
when we were a few tracks in and we were
like listening with our eyes closed
or I was listening with my eyes closed
this is 12 karat toothpick so it's like
if you've listened to it you know that a
number of places it gets pretty moody
like it's not it's not all Party Anthem
type stuff and then I would
open my eyes and realize that
post Malone is sitting next to me wait
yeah listen listening to this album and
again we just don't have a lot of
experiences like this because we're not
like we're not we don't try to be part
of a scene we don't like we're just our
lives are
strikingly normal in almost every way
except for these little moments and
I was just like this is a this is a
memory I was like this is a special
moment yeah so if so and we listen to
the entire thing incredible experience
uh also they play it so loud I felt like
it was like literally like shaking my
spleen
and then it's like literally 3 30 A.M
and he's like
well let me
okay yeah what did he say he was like oh
are we supposed to record something
yeah
in earlier that night when we were
talking about
um like our favorite artists and we were
talking about Sturgill Simpson and all
this stuff
um we also started talking about the
Fleet Foxes
yeah which is you know from our top
albums uh episode like we both
they're like have like their form like
albums that are like very formative and
like our our Musical
lexicon you know
um and he's a huge fan
and so then he was like play him play
him the track
and then he was like Robin who is Fleet
Foxes what came in here a few weeks ago
and we started working on something and
then he plays a track
and it's just it's just vote um
vocalizations and then the Beat Drops
and then it's an instrumental so there's
there's no there's no vocals at all and
he plays that and that was like
um before we listened to the whole album
it was just like oh this is just
something that we created together and
so I'm flipping out because it's like
two of my favorite artists working
together and one was in the room with me
playing it and it's just a preliminary
track which they didn't say it would be
anything so then fast forward to at this
point in the evening when it's like oh
man I forgot I was supposed to work
so he goes into the booth and then
that's the track that he plays
and he
so this so this is the song that ended
up being the love hate letter to alcohol
right yeah so
he this is we saw his process which was
essentially going into a booth
and Lou starts playing this track and he
just starts singing over it
literally just kind of ad-libbing and
making it up so long yeah and it was
like he's creating this situation where
he's at the bar and yeah like I woke up
on the ground it's like I got my he
started singing about his teeth getting
knocked out and then at one point like
after about 10 15 minutes of like
riffing on stuff he comes out and he's
like
how many teeth Google how many teeth how
many teeth are in the human mouth and he
had said 32 and we Googled it and it was
32 yeah I I didn't you Googled it and
you're like yes this there's there I
have 32 teeth in my mouth the dentist
told me I'm like in like a very low
percentage of people that still has
their wisdom teeth at my age oh you
don't have 30. so if you have that I
don't know if you have to come in you
have 32. I think so so then we told them
that so then he you know if you listen
to the lyrics it's like I
I
um I woke up on the ground
I guess I should have kept that to
myself
sometimes I'm too good at running my
mouth but not good enough
and then it's
well yeah last night I had 32 teeth in
my mouth but some went away that's the
lyric
and any time we did not realize that he
was that this song was going to be on
the album but because the way he
presented the album was basically like
this is it this is it any kind of uh you
need it he didn't he just implied like
oh I'm still recording something
he actually uh this is pretty cool just
like you know a week later
texted us like here's here's where
here's where the track ended up yeah he
was like we finished it and I was like
oh man he's finished his track and then
lo and behold
it ends up being on the album and then
come full circle oh and then the next
thing he goes he performs on Saturday
Night Live and he performs that song
with Fleet Foxes backing him up yeah
like on stage it was like dude I was
uh and then we had we got to see him in
concert when um
of course he performed the song so which
is amazing that was the only one thing
I'll add
to this story which is a moment I
remember is when I was sort of
reluctantly I think actually you said
something about it I didn't want to talk
about it like talked about the fact that
I was working on my own music uh because
I didn't want to be the the internet
comedian who was like well I'm working
on my music
and uh so
I was like yeah I'm doing like a country
thing and so he he grabs his guitar his
famous acoustic guitar that's got all
the like signatures on it and holds it
out to me he's like play a song
and I was like no I was like I I don't
I'm not ready for that I don't remember
that yeah yeah I oh I remember it yeah
that was pretty that was that was pretty
early early evening that was when we
were doing the Brooks and Dunn but it
was early in your like I had not heard
anything no at that point I didn't have
a I was not prepared to like I had
written the songs but I was like I can't
like I I still I can't do it you know
I'm glad I didn't do it what a surreal
but it was a very serial night and then
so then we call an Uber and we like get
in the Uber to come home
like 3 30. no it was like four four in
the morning like 4 30 maybe honest like
we don't yeah we're not we're not used
to this experience in this hour of the
of the morning and when we get in the
Uber the first song that's playing is
his new song with the weekend
you just played for us yeah he just
played for us it was just so yeah it was
Wild Man surreal yeah and
you know
he's a sweetheart the dude best guy ever
the dude it's not hype it's not hype
he's unlike any any uh celebrity of that
of that level of Fame then that we've
ever met that yeah in terms of his
authenticity yeah a night to remember my
number two well I'm sorry but we just we
we spent a lot of time on it so well
before we keep going on the list uh we
want to remind you about our end of year
sale at mythical.com this is going to be
through the 26th uh through from the
26th of uh December through the 31st so
very end of the year
um and basically the way this works is
the more money you spend at mythical.com
the more you save so 10 off orders of 50
or more 20 off orders of 100 or more and
30 off orders of 150 or more ten percent
off twenty percent off thirty percent
this is all items if they're a sale item
if they're not sale item no code
necessary this is for everyone
go to mythical.com you're going to be
surprised at what you find
and what you want spend that spend that
money that you that's your grandma gave
you for the holidays
so this is my number eight number eight
my number eight okay so 2022 was the
year of new therapist for me I was
looking back at my Google photos and
January 1st
I had a photo of a business card that
Christy gave me
you know and she was and I talked about
this at some point early on in the year
about like making making the switch and
I I think a lot of the process happened
around this time last year on the
podcast about thinking talking about my
therapy experience getting your feedback
kind of hearing myself out loud
um realizing that I needed to make a
change I needed to find a better fit and
I will say that
um two weeks ago like my one of my most
recent therapy appointments
like right around Thanksgiving
um
it was I when I got home from that
therapy moment Christy asked me what she
always does how's therapy and I said for
the first time I was like it was great I
I really
am so I'm so glad that
I met this guy and that he's my
therapist and this is working out so
well and
um because I just told him in the
session it was one of those sessions
that was um
it ended up kind of being a celebration
session you know we had we had tackled a
number of things and you know it's
therapy's never done Rhett but there's
certain points when it's like and and
yes it was Thanksgiving so it was kind
of an appropriate time but it just so
happened a time out that way that
you know coming back from some of the
other things on the list like mythicon
related stuff and but just a culmination
of things that we were working on
bringing me to a point
um mentally and emotionally to be able
to not only
whether the trials and process things
but also to be more present for the
highlights like the things on this list
um you know
I really was able to
be grateful for how therapy brought me
to that point where I was able to more
fully experience
um the highs and the lows I guess you
would say and that was something that we
ended up talking about and I was able to
tell him you know what I'm I'm thankful
for all these things and I'm also
thankful for you this is really working
out
and um
it it took you know that was it's like
11 months in and it's all along the way
it was mostly positive indications
but at a certain point you realize okay
I think this is I think this is my I
think this is my guy I think this is my
person and um yeah made it it just made
a huge difference in my year so it's
like 2022 the year of kind of kind of
getting that in place
um realizing that
I'm no longer approaching a session with
anxiety about the session
like that I'm that I have I'm at ease
and I I there's this level of trust and
confidence that what you know it'll be
what it'll be and I've seen it go in so
many different directions that I've
realized that I've loosened up and I've
kind of I'm able to let go of
that particular hang up which has been
very difficult for me
um
I'm I'm good at like putting myself out
there
but and I still don't know exactly what
I would label it like the sense of like
control and relationship to anxiety and
all that but like
it it was always a hurdle to overcome
and just to realize that that had been
like severely lowered to the point where
it's like basically not there anymore
um
is huge yeah that's not like something
that it's not a uh a homework assignment
or like something that you have to have
something prepared for or performative
yeah and um you know uh early on
in in starting our conversations this
was a topic of conversation so I I kind
of invited that level of conversation
that it that on occasion not every
session but he would check in on that
front like how are you processing me
like how how is what I'm saying
like it it was helpful that like I was
able to set the table you know so
I know when you we we gush about therapy
and I just want to acknowledge that like
sometimes
you know therapy is work but then
there's a that for for me and maybe for
a lot of people there's like a whole
other layer of work to be able to get to
do that neural therapy work you know and
um
you know so if my 22 2022 story can like
give people hope that like it's
it's worth it and you know what if
that's
if it's um
if the thing that's keeping you from
therapy is therapy then uh it's still
worth it it's still worth it and it may
take going through a few people to find
to find that right fit uh but don't give
up
amen look at that see how inspirational
this can be
um this is I'm gonna you know just I'm
gonna move through some of these yeah I
got some quicker ones after this um
number seven is going to see movies with
Shepard uh and I would say the specific
moment is us going to see the horror
movie smile together
obviously now that lock is off at
college
uh Shepherd and I spend a fair amount of
time together and our thing is going to
see movies together and we both love
horror movies and we both have very
similar taste and music and movies in
general and it's kind of our little
thing and so much so that
you know uh ever since the ArcLight
closed all these theaters in town are
AMC Theaters that's pretty much where
you go is if you're going to go to a
theater you go to an AMC theater and
they're constantly selling this AMC
Stubs membership right oh did you get
that so
every single time we show up at the
theater and we see the people in the
yellow line getting to the concessions a
little bit faster Shepard's like Dad we
need to why why aren't we stubs members
and then we go in and we and they have
then they give the ad for the stubs
membership and then they do the Nicole
Kidman uh you know that that wonderful
little thing that happens before AMC
movies I just we just and people clap
every time going to see a movie in LA
and I I know this probably happens
elsewhere but like
I haven't heard him clap for that Nicole
Kidman Park well you haven't been to the
AMC theater yes I have every single time
what Nicole Kidman comes on everybody
claps and giggles and says oh yeah and
then and then when she finishes
everybody claps because there's the
thing I was talking to Shepherd about is
that like being in the entertainment
capital of the world and watching these
movies that are all pretty much you know
like there's a connection between every
movie in Los Angeles even if it was made
somewhere else and so many people are in
the industry and so there's the cynicism
and sort of Insider mentality to
watching entertainment so that when like
a bad movie trailer comes up yeah like
there we just watched there was a
trailer for a new movie called plane
have you seen that yeah and the whole
place burst out laughing as soon as it
said plane because it looks like the
worst movie ever made Gerard Butler and
then it says plane I just love kind of
watching movies in that atmosphere and
people stick around for the credits
because they're like I might know
somebody in those credits at the end you
know yeah
um but anyway so so not a sponsor though
huh well literally right before we went
to our most recent movie which we went
to see Glass Onion on your
recommendation and it was great oh yeah
uh we signed up for the the membership
not the top level where you get three
movies a week because we can't I can't
see three movies a week I just got the
one where we get like the free upgrades
on concessions we get the shorter line
and then we get points that we can use
yeah yeah yeah Brian knows what's up
this is a sponsor
um is this a sponsor it's not I'm not a
sponsor it could be anyway it's been a
real we we have this Shepherd and I have
a great relationship it's tough to get
Shepard to talk unlike Locke who will
talk about everything but going to see a
movie with Shepard we talk about the
movie all the way back home like that
gets him talking he's like well I don't
know this and that I mean he's got all
these opinions about everything and he
really opens up and starts talking so
that's been I love that and when
specifically like smile we talked about
how it was the perfect horror movie
until
they did what every horror movie does
and they show you the monster in a way
that ends up being like
uh this isn't as good as I wanted it to
be but was there a was there a point
when you realized
this is my this is the opportunity to to
stay with that buzzword
and I guess it wasn't smile when you
were like when you're like to get the
AMC Stubs no dude
this is the opportunity to finally buy
the bullet no dude when you're like
this is
this is my this is my connection or one
of
my connections this is like
this is an easy card I can play to like
get in with Shepard and find something
that it can be our thing I don't know if
there was a moment it's just it's more
as I was thinking about it for for for
this and realizing how many movies we
had seen together and how we'd really
connected in that way and how it I've
been at the same time talking to Jesse
about how man you know I take Shepard to
school sometimes and like we can go the
whole he just wants to listen to music
and like I'll ask him a couple questions
he gives me one word answers typical 14
year old yeah
um and he's not being
a jackass he's just like I'm going to
school I don't talk about things right
now yeah
um
uh so no it's just more like reflecting
on it being like Oh we we really talk
about a lot of things and it also the
tenor of our conversation moved from a
dad trying to be a dad which happens
often with me uh right meaning like okay
well you need to be doing this you need
to be doing this here's some advice
here's just talking about your
schoolwork
moves us out common interest of that
Dynamic into just like two guys talking
about movies which is uh which is great
for us that's awesome
um my number seven is my
DJ Elkhound snuggle baby Journey number
seven not that DJ Elkhound snuggle baby
is my name it's just out snuggle baby
but it I'm just clarifying my DJ Journey
maybe maybe in a second parenthesis
after a snuggle baby it's just DJ
because you don't want people to call
you DJ L count snuggle baby you could be
Elkin snuggle baby DJ I have to
I was giving up the opportunity to DJ
our mythical Christmas party because I
only have one freaking arm
and then um sad really I don't but I'm
not going to I'm still going to do it
yeah right yeah because I just do it
with one arm I'll have I'll have been in
the uh
in the Baby Bjorn in front of me are you
going full suit
I think I have to I haven't have you
tried that always I haven't thought
about it I haven't thought about any of
this yet
but
big I mean it was the it was the year of
the Genesis of Elkhound snuggle baby
so yeah
that's it I've already talked a lot
about it we dedicated a whole episode to
it so let's keep going okay uh number
six for me was getting covered
I thought about putting on listen I
forgot uh you know
so many people at this point most people
have gotten it
and it has been I was actually thinking
just the other day
about how we're about to transition into
2023 and I remember at the very
beginning of all this and uh March 2020
talking to our good friend Mike mccarg
smartest guy I know
thanks and uh he
was talking to us about
covet at that time
and you know he's smart and so he was
like we'll still be talking about and
dealing with this directly in 2023 and I
was like Mike you crazy man now first of
all
you know there's been so much I you know
I get on my soapbox about being
frustrated about the covet thing and
covered denial and that kind of thing
but one of the things that I've thought
about recently is how
everything that they said everything
that the the epidemiologist said in 2020
essentially happened they said that we'd
still be talking about and dealing with
this in 2023 they said that almost
everyone was going to get it they said
that it was the this is the number of
people that were going to die within a
certain range go back and look at what
they were they said and every single
thing that they said within those ranges
is what ended up happening because these
things operate according to models and
it's just interest it's just an
interesting thing to to to to to note
they didn't get everything right but it
was just but here we are transitioning
into 2023
we are still dealing with it and talking
about it now not nearly to the same
degree it's not nearly as disruptive as
it was and you know all indications are
that it's sort of dwindling it's
becoming every time we start talking
about it it's a little bit less of an
issue and then eventually it's just like
yeah we don't really talk about think
about this very much unless you're in a
super high-risk Group whatever that's
great by the time you got it which is
also within a week of when I got it it's
totally separately yeah
it was
it
like mentally it felt totally different
than like all the different iterations
of how I thought I would respond to it
beforehand well I had gotten to this
place which I think a lot of people have
got to which was maybe I'm immune to it
I mean some people are you know some
people just don't get it just because of
some genetic predisposition
and uh of course that turned out to not
be the case but that ended up being when
I got it I got it from My Wife and then
spent
a week in a hotel room in Chapel Hill
with her and that was a very
um
interesting experience for the the both
of us literally being in a hotel room
and not leaving the hotel room except to
go out onto the balcony of the hotel
room thank God there was one of those
um for about five days and it just was
this I you know I have my aura ring uh
which is not a sponsor but we are
investors uh so maybe they should be but
it gives you all your vitals and stuff
and you know I go back and I can and you
can look at all your data and I look at
the data for that week
and I see my temperature of like a
hundred and three and a half I think is
what I got to two nights in a row in my
like HRV you know heart rate variability
was like super low it's like my
Readiness score was like in the 30s it
was like the lowest it's ever been
and it was like that was a tough that
was a tough time but it's a it's a time
that almost everybody has had to
experience on some level and obviously
it's been devastating and continues to
be devastating for a lot of people
whether you you know you know somebody
who lost their lives or you're just
somebody who's dealing with long covet
so it's just my personal
direct encounter with covid after having
encountered all its effects as just a
member of society I think that would
kind of crystallize in 2023 thankfully I
haven't gotten it again and
who knows if when or if I'll get it
again but
it was memorable it was a moment I've
lost track
of
the number of boosters that I've gotten
at this point I think it's three is it
four
I don't know yeah I don't know all of
them
yes sign me up man
sign me up I'm in the cult I love to get
boosted
um let's see my number six was the
launch of dispatches from Myrtle Beach
oh yeah
um
because as my dad and I talk about
many times on the podcast itself it's
just
we're just realizing like wow it just
gives us this new touch point for our
relationship to like move I would it's
not
it's to a new level in some ways because
it's um like the just the frequency
and the depth of our connection are both
like on another level
um but it's also expanded the nature of
our relationship in a way that I don't
believe ever would have happened if it
wasn't for the podcast I mean
to to know that every week I'm going to
have it it ends up being like a 45 50
minute conversation that then uh Logan
cuts down to 30 minutes
right um because after all my dad is in
charge of the episode so something you
just gotta tighten up or maybe remove
um maybe she removes some of the stuff
that I say too I bet good
two peas in a pod man but yeah it's like
we are interacting with each other on
different terms
it's it's about
having fun
like high value and having fun and also
just connecting with each other so we
find ourselves answering questions that
people have emailed or asking I'm asking
him questions like
whoa so what went into naming me I mean
I know that I'm the third and you're
junior it's like I'd actually never
heard like his thoughts about that like
how long was he thinking about there
being a third before he was even
um you know thinking about having was it
his kids
well yeah he was a junior and it was
just kind of it was kind of similar to
how I thought about Lincoln but the it
wasn't
it wasn't that it was a revolutionary
answer but that it was a a a a
conversation we had never had talked
about it you know and it's it's one
thing to talk about like okay you taught
you call if I call my dad on the phone
he'd be like I had a prostate exam
they're doing some tests
I decided not to tell you about it until
I got the results and they're fine you
know it's like that's how the
conversation would have gone but like on
the podcast it becomes this like
it all of that the important part of the
conversation still happens that like oh
I I care about you I want to make sure
that your prostate's good but then it's
also the most fun version of the
conversation that that we'll have you
know it's like
seen him grow
and like you know there's you've seen
this from me many times I'll come out of
this room and I'll go back into our
office and if you're in there
I'm just like I'm proud of my dad
because he is he's actually he's
developing he's really understanding the
parts of this that he needs to
understand but then continuing to not
develop in the ways that I don't want
him to develop so that it stays like
entertaining in that right way so it's
like
um like this the the way that he decides
to prepare like the things that he
brings to the table like he's fully
committing himself to to this and
I I am surprised at how much of
him
is in me that is brought me to this
point it's like as much as I knew it
I'm still surprised by the exactly
you're getting to experience it the yeah
the extent of it so it's like
it's I was you know I I didn't want to
get my hopes up when when we decided to
do it I was very reticent to like
like fully commit to it mentally it's
like oh it's just something we'll do for
a little bit and you know all good
things come to an end but like there's
no end in sight for dispatchers from
Myrtle Beach and I think it It
ultimately comes down to the experience
that we have with each other
and then it's up to the it's it's up to
an audience to like know what they want
to be a part of that and like it enough
people are
I in my opinion the audience still needs
to grow I would love to I'd love for
more people to know about it and hear
about it and it's challenging to know
how to get a podcast out there
um
but absolutely on the list you know it
um it could probably be higher but it's
my number six
he is he has fully embraced
um
his
his role and that wasn't something that
was guaranteed no
um my number five
is my trip with lock from Maine to Miami
which we did a whole episode on it's a
big one the specific moment
from that trip is our walk around the
the Washington Mall
yeah around the you know The Monuments
at night
um and you know because of the time that
we recorded this episode last year we
always record it before the end of the
year
technically my other road trip with luck
which was in December of 2021
when we had to drive back from North
Carolina to California those two road
trips
with lock
I think fundamentally changed the
dynamic of our relationship which
fundamentally changed
the dynamic of our relationship that
exists now while he's at college right
yeah so it's funny how
and I think this is it makes me think
about these moments in a different way
and because a lot of the things that we
will list are things that are outside of
the ordinary experience a lot of the
things will be in our trips that you
went on right yeah we talked about this
before but
doing something and this is why I tell
Shepard you know go go to a summer camp
like do these things go on a trip take
advantage of this opportunity because
shaking your life up and doing this
short-term thing yeah when you look back
on your life it'll be the things that
took you out of your normal routine
that's what you will remember those will
be the formative experiences those will
be the times in which you like put your
mouth up to a fire hydrant and and
basically ingest it and experience at a
much higher rate than you do in your
normal life
and
those two trips would lock her a
testament to it just being in a car
together going across the country just
the two of us and I think it was a
five-day trip and then maybe maybe a
five or six day trip so we're talking
about 10 to 11 days of time that helped
Define our Dynamic and I think helped us
move in the same way that this I'm
talking about with Shepherd it moved
from
so much of this dad and son Dynamic
which for me ends up being the uh what
is my role in in giving them the best
advice and guiding them which is
important
yeah but moving to that connection which
is as a kid becomes an adult
goes off to college becomes independent
the dynamic that you want to continue
and the only Dynamic that's worth
continuing is the connection dynamic
because the guidance Dynamic the
parenting Dynamic goes away and actually
in many ways becomes a burden to them as
they become adults right and I see a lot
of relationships a lot of parent and
child relationships that as the child
becomes an adult doesn't matter how old
they get it doesn't matter how much
experience they get under their belts it
doesn't matter if they become parents or
not the dynamic remains a parent and a
child you will always be my child and I
will always need to guide you and I will
always need to call you out
and that Dynamic can be really
detrimental to relationships and I'm not
saying that I engineered this or I read
a book I got lucky in a lot of ways by
just the first trip was a circumstance
we needed to make a trip because uh the
way plans changed uh and then we because
that one went so well we decided to do
another one and those two trips in short
succession I think
um is the reason that we talk on the
phone all the time now
in a way that we did in a way that we
didn't huh in a way that we just we
didn't communicate with that frequency
in that depth and it's actually it's
increased the timing of it was so cool
and the funny thing is is I don't
remember if it was this episode last
year
no it was it was when you did your
episode about sending
Lily off to college
and I was kind of reflecting as you were
talking and at the end of that episode I
remember saying something like I really
want to focus on making this year a year
of connection with lot because we had
been at each other's throats like he had
a really difficult time with covid and
and basically not going to school not
being able to see his friends
and
that created a lot of tension between us
that really ran a risk of
just carrying this sort of butting heads
thing off into the rest of our relation
even as you talk about your dad it's
like these little decisions
it's it sometimes it's just little
decisions that can change the trajectory
of a relationship it's it's kind of
fascinating
so that's my number awesome dude uh I'm
gonna I'm gonna refer to a lot of that
with my number four but I've gotta say
my number three first which is
um
mythicon
and I wanted to be specific about this
because
mythicon was a was was an amazing
experience
uh so I'm pinpointing our main stage
performance like
oh I've already said it like the most
phone we've ever had on stage I just
felt like it was a culmination of so
many things that we had learned and this
relationship we have with the mythical
Beast that it was just like
I mean
Good Mythical evening is not on not on
my not on my list but like everything
that we don't remember everything we did
brought us to a point where it's like we
can I don't know there's just like there
was a level of trust there that's
certainly Good Mythical evening was
instrumental and kind of building
um but everything was so I just felt
like it was it was a great experience
and and I'll never forget it just how
much fun that we had on stage my dad was
a part of it like I'll never forget the
like the reaction that everybody had to
chase coming out like that particular
moment for me was like
really satisfying you know it's like it
wasn't just about us riding in on a bike
but it was about this world that we had
created that now
these people were experiencing with us
it was just so much it was so much fun
and like the level of unhinged
creativity that we put into it has given
us
even more confidence with how we are
approaching 2023 and we got this twinkle
in our eye baby
and I think it's really about
it's those moments from this year that
that moment for me from mythicon is
something that like just really
gets me excited about
what can we do next
what can we create
well don't talk too much about that
because I I've captured that as a as a
point in a different way related to
mythicon but mythicon is my number one
oh snap
um mythical oh and I actually so when I
obviously I agree with everything that
you just said in terms of uh I was done
the the the stage show uh being
incredibly special and this incredible
moment
um I think for me
the I my performance with Jesse that
first night well is that if that's your
number one save it is is is
save it for your number one I feel like
that's different
well but it was really mythicon in total
but like if I had to pick a point in
which I was like this moment is
something I will absolutely never forget
and don't and don't know how I could
ever engineer it again it would be that
moment well let's all come back to that
come back to it I think that's separate
from but I well I might I mean but
number four in general was was you know
releasing human overboard okay
um
which again I've talked about
extensively I'm not going to talk about
it extensively here
um
but this was just for all the reasons
that I've covered a
really significant
moment for me and I think that
there's so many things about it and the
way that things have been received and
the stories that people have told and
uh that have been just very deeply
enriching
I think that
one element of it that stands out is
being able to to you know record the
song with Jesse
and where we're going songs you know of
course you've recorded a few of them
with me but that one in particular
because it's about her recording it with
her and then uh being able to make that
music video with her which involved me
having to go and find this footage from
our relationship and go into the
archives of our honeymoon
tapes you know we had like four hours of
old vhsc or digital eight tapes from a
honeymoon
about an hour and a half of that was me
literally just filming like the stage
show at the resort we were at I was such
an idiot like anybody who does that and
I'm included in that is an idiot like 90
seconds of it was sex tape if you just
if you go like it's one thing to go to a
concert and like get footage of it so
you can say I was there and post
something on social media it's another
thing to like to say I want to
re-experience this entire to think that
you were making the concert film
like you're making the concert film on
your freaking phone or your little
stupid ass camera yeah you were a
dumbass that's a dumbass thing to do and
I've done it too many times okay I I
just I'll just admit
but uh but especially young and in love
especially when you're at a not very
nice all-inclusive resort in Cancun
Mexico that the only Resort that you
could afford at the time hey
you did you enjoyed it let me just say
this Talent the talent pool
of this particular Resort when it's like
this people like these I love how you
turn into your what are your top moments
of the year like these performers these
dudes that they're like doing beat it
like one of them's just like Michael
Jackson oh wow yeah you got to
understand what I'm talking about man
it was awful wow and I filmed it I have
it
anyway going back and finding that
footage in those photos
um was this like man because what the
James and the shame project and human
overboard sort of represents is this
sort of musical expression of the
process of my deconstruction and
thinking about this woman my wife Jesse
who's been there from the beginning and
has gone through this on her own pace at
her own pace
um
and then looking back at our
relationship in those early days when we
were just like man look at those 20 look
at that 23 year old and that 20 year old
who got married
you know uh and and got married
for you know and in a lot of ways
because I wanted to have sex with each
other because that was the only way they
could pick them up on the first time
and to see how we've managed we got
through
we got out of a particular world that
I'm very happy that we got out of and we
are sort of traversing through a Brave
New World together in a way that you
know I wouldn't trade for the world
but that but so that that moment with
her is really the the Pinnacle of that
for me but in general the whole uh music
thing has been deeply rewarding my
number four is
um it's
I've said it's my scuba diving there's
like my scuba diving Journey but really
that's it's it's really about my
relationship with Lincoln this year and
it's so much of like what you described
in terms of having a pivotal
year and like these special moments with
lock like
deciding to get scuba certified
Lincoln's saying he was totally on board
and excited about that so it became a
thing that we were doing together
leading up to going to Maui and like
swimming through these like volcanic
caves and then
um
but the whole certification process like
having to take the class and having to
take you know all of it and um
it was it was a it was a huge project
that had this big payoff and then it has
this long tail I guess you would call it
of like Adventures that we can have
together and it it's it's a special
thing in a year that like okay now
lilies out of the house
and me realizing that you know it's okay
so the things that Lily and I could
connect with like the things that we'd
watch on television
you know the shows and the movies like
that was a big connection point for us
it was it was kind of like right there
at the ready and
Lincoln Lincoln's quiet he like he plays
into like the middle child Trope a lot
like he's such a peacemaker and like he
doesn't he doesn't seem to be needy you
know so it's like me identifying that I
need I've got to find my ways in
um and so scuba diving and that whole
journey really became that for us
I'll also say you're using your right
arm just so you know it's out of the
sling it's making me nervous it's like a
snake approaching you're now you're
beginning to gesture with it it doesn't
hurt okay it's just I'm not a doctor
because I'm leaving it on the table it's
like there's no weight on it I'm just
gonna push I'm I can gesture with my
hand I need to gesture with my hand okay
and I also need to like air out my
armpit because that's why you took it
out yeah okay it's just a little swampy
in there
thank you though as long as I keep the
right posture
and then I just you're like I just want
that thing to heal
um I need two arm to link me too ASAP
thank you for looking out for me I'm
good I think this is actually a good
place to be
so
um the scuba diving Journey was that and
also
we started going to more concerts
together like we went to the weekend
which you may have seen me on Tick Tock
went to the Kendrick show we went to uh
a postie show and he got to meet him
backstage and like and got to meet ski
mask the slump God you got to wear that
his Medallion yeah he's um
so you know Lincoln and I do really
connect over music but like going to
shows
has taken that to a new level so then
he's bringing me shows like hey let's go
to this
and then it's
sometimes it's like well
I'm going to this with my friends he's
like well you know if I can go to
Lincoln I'll buy Here ticket it's kind
of like the deal pretty good but I'm
also like now if you want to do some of
this stuff without me there or like if
we if you want to have if you want to
have a little bit of Separation I
totally understand so it's like I'm
trying to be sensitive that like
um of course I totally blend in
well I mean I think you kind of do you
seen the way you've been dressed
I mean so the music thing is like a a
big connection for us and so we have a
good time uh going through those events
together so between that and the scuba
diving I'm kind of lumping that in
together is like the year of of like
finding those connection points that and
the time there's time associated with it
like so much happens within the context
of just like protecting time to be
together
you know um it's not about just the
saying the right things having the right
conversations you gotta you gotta you
gotta like set the set the table you
know what I'm saying yeah which I
definitely hear in your road trip those
experiences it's like with no low
pressure yeah where you can like exit
dad mode and you can just like enjoy
each other's company and have a common
interest so finding that
um
has been a this was a defining year for
us
for that and you know I was talking at
the dinner table last night and I was
like you know we're putting this episode
together and I was really happy that
Lincoln was like uh our concerts you
know like that's what he said you know
he was because I was just kind of
curious what what everybody would bring
up and the fact that that's what he said
even above this this it's been more
recent than scuba We're Not In Scuba
mode because it's it's cold
I think he would have said that a few
months ago so like
this is registering with him as well so
it feels good man
my number three
is um
the way I would describe it is US
deciding to make decisions from the soul
okay yes and
there's a lot there's a lot to say here
but I don't want to say a lot so I
essentially we've hinted at this a
number of times that in 2023 we are
making some changes in terms of the way
we think about the content that we make
obviously we're going to continue to
make good mythical morning we're going
to continue to make this podcast it's
going to continue to make his podcast
we're going to continue to be the you
know Founders and CEOs of mythical
entertainment which takes a lot of time
um
but what we have been doing over the
past few years has been taking some of
our most ambitious creative ideas and I
would say our most concentrated Creative
Energy and focusing it into
other projects that we try to get off
the ground in a more traditional way
meaning a TV show a film putting
together a pitch for a show there's been
scripts that have been written there's
been lots of Worlds that have been built
and developed and these things take a
lot of time and there's things that
we've been very passionate about
and there are still a few of those
things that are at some point in a
process that may eventually result in it
being a reality
but there's a series of things that
happened this year uh some things I'll
keep vague just because we need to but
um there are some that we don't need to
keep vague you know we our Our Food
Network show didn't get picked up again
right we we did four episodes of it
inside eats it didn't we didn't get any
more of it there's a number of reasons
for that all things dreaming that are
outside of our control Maybe
um but honestly you know if I am honest
about that project be honest while it
did it was our thing in some ways
because it was developed in the context
of a network it was like make the show
that Food Network wants us to make and
then try to make it as Rhett and linky
as we possibly can
or as mythical as we can you know the
final product ends up being something
that ostensibly can work on Food Network
which isn't necessarily something that
we would have made from the get right
it isn't necessarily a product that
looks like it came from our soul is what
I'm getting at
um a number of things that were at
certain points in development we were
told no
finally no where no one's interested in
this no we don't want to see this from
you no we don't want you guys to make
this thing
and then at the same time we said no to
something an opportunity that we had a
big opportunity an opportunity that
could have significantly changed things
for us and our lives
um and we said no
and there's a lot of things that went
into saying no and I think that
one of the things that I've been
thinking about a lot this year and
especially lately
and a lot of the things I've been
reading and you know I just finished
Victor Frankel's Man's Search for
meaning which is a very short and
compelling read I recommend every it's
like four and a half hours if you want
to just listen to the audible I have
read it uh yeah and so
and I'm re and I'm starting on this new
book where this guy's kind of talking
about the concept of Dharma which is
kind of like you're you know like your
life's calling and purpose and I I
realize that me and you have always had
a really clear sense of who we are and
what we are trying to do in the world
but many times in practice
we have executed things in a way that
actually looked more like this is what
people want from us
rather than this is what we want to do
and this is what we want to make
and I don't want to like over promise
and under deliver I'm not saying that
we're about to like create our magnum
opus or something like that but
there's been a significant shift
in my mind to thinking about the way
that we are uniquely Rhett and Link
and uniquely positioned
to make things that only we can make not
in a qualitative or not in a make
something better than everybody
or see it in a competitive way like
we're on this competitive website and
there's these new creators who are
really popping off on the platform and
we've got to get in the mix and we've
got to do something new and we've got to
innovate which is the way that I've
thought in the past a lot of times
but as I've gotten older
it's less about that and it's
recognizing the opportunity that we have
the fact that we have this incredible
audience this incredible support group
this incredible in many ways friend
group that are the mythical beasts that
have decided that I'm kind of into the
idea that these guys just try things
with us and for us
and recognizing that those are the
people that I want to be making things
for
because those are the people
that are so supportive of us digging
deep
and sort of coming from things coming
from the soul like ideas and creative
ideas and a creative expression that
comes from the soul that only that is a
is a creative expression that only we
can make
and I'm very excited about what that
means for
the future of the content that we're
going to create I love the fact that you
decided to put this on the list I you
know
um I didn't put it on the list because
we're trying to figure out how we talk
about the decisions that we made and I
think he did a really good job
you know for the things that we have
said no to and for like the big
decision that we made
um ever since then I have had this
growing sense of excitement and
um you know what just just to go back to
the
the way that we used to talk just this
piece about it you know just feeling
very much like yes
we
made the right choice it wasn't
it wasn't an easy choice but when it
when it had to be made it was obvious
and yeah I'm sorry to be vague but like
I think the reason why
I'm glad you mentioned it even though
we're deciding to keep it vague is
because
this was the year that we made that
which in some ways could be you know it
is definitely one of the weightiest
decisions we've ever made
oh yeah ever
and um
yeah and to
to not have not to not look back
and and to feel like very confident that
when I'm never gonna look back on that
decision feels really good and
because we have so much to look forward
to that is
everything that you said that what we're
true to ourselves and
um
realizing
the amazing opportunity we have
that that were that we are currently
living our dream and that
uh
that's it's such a privilege and again
it's that word opportunity it's like you
you say you don't want to over promise
and under deliver well yeah because we
don't we don't have the specific plants
you know we have we have lists and we
have we're just starting this next phase
of what we're going after and it's not
specific at this point but it's uh
it's the right trajectory and it's it's
exciting and I and you know so sorry for
being vague but hopefully even with the
vagarity of it that it's not frustrating
but exciting
that we cannot be vague about is we're
going to be making
internet videos like we're going to be
making content that we put on YouTube
and as opposed to spending all this time
developing all these things that go into
a boardroom somewhere so that begins in
2023 but I'm it's important that it's on
this list for us collectively because
it's a it's a 2022 decision I mean it's
a it's a it's in some ways it's it's a
culmination of everything we've done but
definitely over the past two years
you know and I am bringing us to this
point and I also think it's funny
there's a lot of little things that uh a
lot of it is just being at this stage in
our career in our lives and
circumstances and that kind of thing and
you just start thinking like what am I
doing like uh but just so you know
as this relates to Good Mythical Morning
you've probably already noticed this a
little bit like but the way that we've
been thinking about Good Mythical
Morning more and more is how it good
mythical morning is our playground Good
Mythical Morning is a framework in which
we are just ourselves we don't come up
with I mean every once in a while we'll
come up with an idea for an episode but
the vast majority of the things that we
do on Good Mythical Morning are ideas
that our team generates it's a form and
orchestrates and so and then we more and
more have seen ourselves as you know
this podcast is a place where we come
and we talk about life for a long time
we're experiencing life together we're
having these conversations we're
processing things that's what it's going
to continue to be if you want to be
around for it you're welcome for it you
know we welcome you along for the ride
but it's not a gimmick it's not like
it's not a gimmick thing it's just two
guys who've known each other forever
talking that's what's what it is right
and we don't want it to be something
that it's not good mythical morning
isn't this place for us to have this
incredibly sophisticated creative
expression it's a place for us to be
ourselves and bring joy and have an
experience together to invite you into
that experience but the thing that we've
been doing is this other huge piece of
ourselves right is this Creative Energy
and passion which ends up getting
funneled into things I mean quite
frankly I think one of the reasons I
ended up doing the James and the shame
thing is not just because of all the
like
like spiritual processing and angst that
was sort of building up and needed to
come out some way but the reason it came
out in a creative way is that sometimes
I feel like this
tank
of Creative Energy and it has to offload
somehow it's got to come out somewhere
it's Gotta somebody's got to open a
valve and this year the valve opened a
little bit and now came this album and
you know and then when you think about
these other projects that we've spent
this time hours upon hours developing
these worlds and these ideas
it was letting some of that creative
steam off but it was sending it into the
ether to be forgotten
and so I think it's like we're taking
that creative tank and we are hooking it
up to a hose that ends on YouTube on a
screen that you can see the final
product
um and we don't exactly know what it
looks like but it's this sort of
spiritual Decision Soul Decision that
feels that feels really exciting and
there are some ideas that we're excited
about but that's where the everything's
being funneled
you know
this brings me to my number three I
think that
like I think my number three to couch it
and everything that we just said is
like the the deeply personal
[Music]
and relational aspect between the two of
us
you know this podcast is a venue where
we talk about our lives and like
a nut like the
arguably the deepest level of our
friendship is on display
but there is a deeper level that is not
on display and that I'm not going to
talk about in this number but I just
want to I I wanted to memorialize the
fact that
there was some key conversations that
you and I had this year that everything
that we just talked about in the
previous point would not be possible
without those conversations that's true
and it was it was it was very formative
it was very
special
and uh
I just wanted to acknowledge that so
that's you know to talk about being
vague like I was going to put that I was
going to put that on my list as well but
I did but I didn't know how to talk
about it yeah and I didn't put the last
on our list so like you know that one
two punch I'm glad I'm glad that we
covered it because
yeah there's a there's a part we have a
relationship that's not for anybody else
you know and I think that you mean our
sexual relationship that's what that you
that's what that's kind of what you make
is you're making it sound like okay no
not it's not a sexual relationship don't
give the Tumblr people anything they uh
I don't already have I mean you can
any way you want to try to interpret it
it's just like I'm not inviting you to
do that that's kind of my point well I
take the way that I would characterize
it is that
um we have uh our our friendship which
is the
backbone of this whole thing
there are times when
um
in fact I I think I can I think I can
say this because I think it speaks to it
uh one of the things we talked about
is in the past you know I remember
specifically there was a question that
we would get asked uh when we were on
our um Bleak Creek tour I don't even
know if it was part it was a ques I
don't we ended up answering this
question maybe just because we get this
question what's the secret to a long
fruitful friendship
and the way that I would always answer
this question was I would say that think
about
um like a marriage and then people have
this baby that they're raising together
and that baby as long as that kid is at
home and they're think about it like a a
career that you're building together
it's like a baby that never leaves home
and so as long as that kid is home
you're both committed to that and I and
and you pointed out that that analogy
while made sense on one level so if
we've always got something that we're
doing together we got something that
brings us together both circumstantially
like well we got to show up at the same
office every single day like so there's
no out of sight out of mind with our
friendship which could happen with old
friends
right but we're always going to see each
other
and so you don't get that but then also
there's like hey we gotta we have to get
through our differences in order to work
together on a common goal so having a
common goal was the way that I would
characterize
I wouldn't say it was the secret but it
was the one that I would bring up and
you made up you made the point that like
well if you carry that analogy all the
way through well the moment that the kid
goes off to college like if you've got a
marriage that's just based on this
common goal of raising a child and the
kid goes off to college and you're empty
nesters and you look at each other and
you're like well who the hell are we
what do we want to hang out
you made the point which I very much
appreciated which was and not that our
friendship didn't not that we haven't
had a friendship but that by thinking
about it in this way versus thinking
about the fact that we have a friendship
that we have to cultivate
that isn't always
cultivated by the Entertainment
Properties that we make together even a
podcast like this that is intensely
personal and authentic and does serve a
great friendship sort of bonding role we
have to have a friendship that exists
outside of the common goals
and I think this year was
a point and this is something that we've
talked about and we've had difficult
very great conversations over the years
but I think that there was a pivotal
moment this year where we had a more
poignant
pointed conversation about it that I
think was
the most
productive conversation that we've ever
like we've ever had about that specific
thing yeah yeah
exactly
so there it is uh
super pivotal I mean
yeah I've already I've already said my
piece so that's that's my number that's
my number three and now that I mean it
could be number one now that
and it probably should at least be
number two now that I'm thinking about
it because I put like us hanging out
with post Malone I knew you were gonna
put this number two I knew you because I
mean listen when you were there I knew
you were having the time in your life
um and I it's great it's the top ten I
mean it's definitely top ten yeah but
I'm officially switching those two okay
I'm putting this one it's tough at
number two it's tough to figure out the
order I'm putting mine number two my
number two uh thank you for saying which
again is a I've done a full episode on
it is dropping lock off at College
um
the the specific moment I remember which
I don't I think I talked about this but
like we
we smoked a cigar together while walking
around
uh
Miami like well like a little Park area
and uh like had like a celebratory cigar
and this is not my idea this is Locke's
ideas yeah yeah just so you know this is
a lockout yeah he wants to have a cigar
with me every time he sees me he's you
know he's 18. I remember being this way
um
and
yeah I think that this has been you know
it's just for all the reasons that I
talked about in the in the in the
episode this you know you got this kid
you got they've been a part of your
family a part of your household for 18
years and then
they're off
living their own life and you're talking
to them on the phone on a regular basis
and you I have seen it multiple times
since then
um but that was
a
a super substantial moment in my life
and his life and our our family's life
so it's
it's going to stand out forever that
moment when I wanted to have my moment
with him and Jesse was like right
putting something in the trailer giving
us something to take to the trash don't
bring that part up again and we didn't
have our moment
that was your moment yeah yeah I'll
never forget that I'll never forget that
Jesse oh that's great okay so I'm I'm
down to my number one which um I did
talk about so I don't I don't have to
like go through all of it again but when
Mom's husband Lewis passed away this
year uh I spent that whole week
after his passing with my mom
and it was like
I did not anticipate how
formative to our relationship that would
be it just seemed like the right thing
to do you know I wanted to be there for
her but then the the quality of the time
that we spent together like
uh you know
me just me and her every night you know
basically having a sleepover
at a point where she was she was going
through such a tremendous loss
um
our relationship
it just became like something that we
will never forget like whenever we talk
on the phone even if it's just you know
um once or twice a month like whenever
it comes like usually it'll still come
up you know it's like it's something
that we both hang on to
and
um I don't yeah I'll uh I know she'll
never forget it I'll never forget it it
was extremely special and
um
again I'm I don't take the credit for it
I think it was just you make a decision
to
to to to to
just be there you know there's like this
time thing you just kind of
make yourself available and then
sometimes
the magical things can happen and that's
that's what happened in my relationship
with my mom and it's so you know when I
put
everything in perspective this year it's
like it's the the moments that and I you
know I hear this in in the things that
you said too and I know you're not
you're number one but like I'm just
given the summary I guess my summary is
not like
the moments are that mean so much to us
are so relational you know it's like it
just all of a sudden you realize that
you've opened up it's like you're
spelunking and you've opened up you've
come into a you're in this little tight
area and then you're in this huge
beautiful
Cavern that you couldn't have
anticipated was there
and being able this year was that I mean
I had that experience in so in in so
many relationships with my dad with my
mom with with my son with my therapist
you know and it's um
and you know it's you don't have to have
it with everybody that I love very
deeply you know it's like maybe that's
not me like Chris and I had some amazing
experiences this year and like like
we're
I'm you know we're ha we have such a
rewarding relationship like I feel like
well shouldn't there be something on my
list there it's like
actually no there doesn't have to be you
know I'm hedging a little bit because I
know that you and Jesse that your number
one is Jesse but like I'll leave it at
that well no actually you know what I've
changed it my number one is the week I
spent with your mom
oh [ __ ] you man damn
that's hilarious
um oh that's fine my number one is is
mythicon in general
and then specifically uh the James and
the shame performance and then even
within that is the moment that Jesse was
with me on stage and even with that in
that the moment where she's saying this
where she's saying the high notes and
kill a man and we had to stop because
people wouldn't stop clapping okay yeah
um
you know I think that this in in many
ways ties back into I mean first of all
it was like
I think one of the things that we're
kind of discovering is that there are
these um
to continue to just use more analogies
because since we like to use those so
much it's just like with each experience
you're like laying a brick you're
building something right what are you
building you know
um and sometimes you realize that oh
I just finished the house like this
thing I didn't even know what I was
building it by investing in yeah in
something it might be a skill it might
be a relationship it might be an
experience that you have you're you're
building something and then it it
there's a result and it's not always
good sometimes you're building bad
things sometimes you're investing in the
wrong relationship the wrong tendency
the wrong habit and then you realize
what then you got to get in that house
and live in it and I think that uh not
that we don't do that but that these are
our highlights for the most part so
we're talking about the good house that
we've built but to me
that moment kind of represents this
all these Investments that I've had the
privilege of making
um
and I think it ties back into my number
three which is this this decision to
like do things more from the soul
because
that moment
when
I was performing doing something that I
really have no right to do who has a
right to do anything but you know
especially you you know okay yeah I made
some internet videos and right now I get
to make country songs and make country
music
um
but the way that it was received and the
fact is is that it could
totally suck and it would still be well
received I mean to a certain degree
um
but there's this Freedom you know and to
see Jesse experience it to have this
like she was so nervous about getting up
on stage so we talked about
and then to see the reception and the
warmth and the support that comes from
the mythical beasts
to me it was just this reminder that so
often I get into a place where I think
about how you do something in a way that
makes it a success in the broadest way
possible
that you impress the most people and
what are the you know what are the
factors by which you judge something
being a success to the most people well
numbers it's we are we're obsessed with
numbers how many followers do you have
how many views did that get how much
money did it make
and we've been pretty damn good at
playing that game for a really long time
right we know how to engineer things in
such a way so that they get numbers and
it generates money but one of the things
that has come about
is this
freedom
and I think that that moment of being up
there
having written these songs and bringing
Jesse and having her perform them with
me and being so well received was this
sort of giant
um
check mark or endorsement on you're
moving in the right direction
when you think about doing things more
from an authentic place of like who you
could the only thing you can beat is
yourself
right
you can try to be what you think other
people want you to be
and I've spent a lot of time doing that
as a three as Indian Grant three
um but to me I think that I don't know
there's a series of events and that one
encapsulates it the most of like the the
kind of the riskiest thing that I did
this year was decide to do this music
and to do it in the context of this
family that has sort of gathered around
our content and to see that oh man like
yeah you can take a chance like that if
you go if you move if you move into the
heart and get out of the head a little
bit and lean into it and create
something from that place what can
happen
um and that's where all my excitement is
in that right now not you know
specifically my music I mean I'm still
writing songs and I'll release more
music but like that's that's not what
I'm talking about I'm talking about
everything as it relates to
us creating things and what we're gonna
do next as it relates to me as an
individual person and the way I show up
in the world the way that I show up in
relationships
thinking about
how does that come more from a soul
place and a place of authenticity rather
than just a I'm trying to fit somebody's
expectations and trying to appear a
certain way
um that's a good number one that's my
number one man this has always been so
rewarding uh my wreck is do the same
we always say
this in these episodes you know it takes
a little bit of work go through your go
through your photos for for this whole
year jog your memory actually make a
list of uh of the things that were
special to you and then if you you know
talking about it or writing down
something beside each thing
uh is kind of a next level of reward
that like I think we just experienced so
that's my recommendation for you to do
the same thing and if you want to share
anything with us that can show up at the
end of another episode as always you can
respond by leaving us a voicemail 188
earpod one or use hashtag your biscuits
wherever hashtags are hashed so have a
good New Year's Eve New Year's Day
because this is the last episode of 2022
but we will be back with another episode
of here biscuits on January 9th
2023. this is Tyler from Kansas City
Missouri I'm talking to you from my car
I just want to let you guys know how
much I appreciate you and listening to
you guys for about 10 years now
you're busy golf every time I drive
uh dad passed away in 2014 and a
majority of what helped me
some of you guys love you hey what's up
red and Link it's your boy Rick I just
finished my first day out alone on a job
that I use a whole bunch of tools whole
bunch a whole bunch of stuff you got to
know and do and I didn't grow up
learning all that stuff man let's say I
was shaking in my boots all day man and
actually I wasn't because I just turned
on some ear biscuits have my had my
little Ear Pod in and man I just
listened the way he kept me calm all day
man I appreciate it thank you all thank
y'all hey Rhett hey link I love you
guys's videos this is so cool I don't
know what I'm gonna be can you put this
on the internet really I didn't know
what I was gonna say I just called the
number I heard it up so you just put
this on the episode
or not he has a boss love you bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]